це і вас в ефірі першого національного
програма про головна програма що
робити шляхи і одразу меншими дискусії
ще до закону порох ви ще світла
підготовка тіла річкового зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання зад ринку з
перетворенням зчеплення звали до неї спали
поруч зарплату 4-го українського світла
традицією на вас управа джек проблеми
просто приватний стану вірші та ланового
рама з міністром про святі науки Дмитро
табачник він метро володимира читаю вас
добрий день у лідку 2010 голосив і про
так званий хіт за поверні не втримав
влада нести дитину дочки в може
грати за раз про результат компанії
чавес то чаю садочку для всіх гід питання
які знаю особливо його в варті
чарлі те щоб свою дотягнули до . що
говорить і про хрестовий похід за
повірені адушкін їх вуста але можна
поважати ще гвинт за явним світом
увінчався успіхом за зараз kings дитини
чикса бті в Україні відбулося на тисячу
триста п'ятдесят установка за голом c
дало новий місяць літаючих садках менше
200 4000 септимів та україні за місцем ки
поступилася ідола тисне новий не близько 80
садочку
і черв'яка всі сили знака і пов'язана з
дуже позитивним моментом то чоловік
стане 3 роки навіть народ, що збився, живо
не структур плюсу і демографія розум
стем хотів би сказати і про дитину корости
навіть коротко ще тут був і все за особин
я здається в природі ми особи зібрав і
вчити судових засіданнях ми петрі
малюка харчування територіальних громад
повернення садочку шляхом ви сьогодні
оренда рим та на вигляд високоякісний
державні установки за галон хочеш
сказати ще на цілі
здогад взагалі досяг 200 4000 плану і
цос творить і створити на 50 тисяч
місць і що говорить із рівня
90 нових сотки та відкриття нових груп та
капітальний ремонт та висилали дати суду
тут рай у норда сідоковий
адміністрації старовинний графік на спіт
прямо вийду жикси
ініціативи та глава тримав і президент
україни та голова уряду
їсть варений адже по видний графік по
всіх областях зараза знаходиться датчик
садочку раптово значенням у всіх
регіонах України
наблизив 800 нм експо діва ще до кінця
терок вбивший 300 буде повернутий і вид
видно місяць і
повік шум і плачено ликова і завальна за
статистика їх про план дітей дошкільним
їх іван нім було 63 сотки на
сьогоднішній день моєму вісімдесят п'ять
з половиною ж сотки
адже побачить і норми як євросоюзу
плив його рекомендую краї нам 2 Європи
червона думаючих або буде тобі поки
розрахунки вас кута його у великих місцях
то хто христовий по хитрі voy a window
двісті чотири тисячі нових місць та
у дунай був ще два роки у планах
міністерство обласних адміністрацій
створить ще он від 100 тисяч місць дати
а чикса дочках ще повністю ставити
сотки ви хочете всіх 5 річок і піднятий
ох обплювань сердитий ці порожнечі спицею
дошкільного 10 го століття до приблизно 80
900 міністерство
свята і науки рф було на виду ж мені
стандарти для дошкільні квіти та
владне за вільну середню та sweet ще
війни вимикають ще місто і про
початкова школа та плану та cisco сунути та
його не фізкультуру скільки наші деталі
так і здоров'я
я до затікав цих дітей на честь я crosman
теж 3
їх не програм ще банани bool1 та довжини
занатос складну одразу милу знає імені
приємно сказати сказати ей було спільне
розрубала міністерство нові стандарти
розривно було табель широкий за gold та
національні університети та педагоги
методисти сухих регіонів у вмовляння не
тільки нових стандартів початку ви і
школи з пропозиціями взяв і долю
на 25000
висвітлять з десятки сотні більше не
у противники до міністерства я сказав би
що c завальний пептид і загальна робота
та шкіра новий стандарт публічно
обговорювався перед ним презентував
все-таки менше ніж у суд не з нових
стандартів світло квітки зміниться і тому
вид знання cent річкового підходу
викладання в польську черву школі треба
переходить я краще країни свиту до
компетентнісного пробачиш і коротше я б
сказав для батька
не дати тільки знання вона в чати дітей
ну саму в 4 і види радий і знання і для
тіла дії пройшла я вас перебив синя
хочу сказати революції у світлі там ще
змі на бали в рот кому ір сену бантики
ланки стандарту c сплив на яскравістю
свити від же в чому у але весь новий знак
стандарті porsche
ми за початку вали ви в чині іноземні
мовляв з 1 класу у всіх школах України
інше наземне буду в читанні seat т.п.
з п'ятого класу раніше було тільки 1 і
наземному про лайдаки та гімназіях та ліцеях
я чоловіку процедура ти вищий за один документ
документі ради Європи
якийсь називається можна висвітлити а
політика україни аналіз то рекомендації
без перемішування цех офіцера до Європи
назвав і досягнувши нині українців у стандартах
мовляв на його свити найбільшими за астану
30 руки в Європі і на такі ж
прийомні слова наші стандарти іван та
міжнародні експерти назвали
лінгвістичну позитивну
а люцію топ-топ пишеться іноземного друга
пошукового вивчення інформатики з
іншого класу раніше було 9 нуал і ну і
стандарти наперед їм випробував їх кейкос
десятках фарбуєш тіла гімназії у всіх
регіонах і набила світу і в столиці
містиці та доступні піт хіт ми серйозно
розван то живих програм ще дало можна
є ж початку школи 1 класу до 12
то більше ти кілька з води на
фізичну культуру нам знову і здоров'я
топ то цілком світі за 100 золота і
здоров'я заощаджуючі технології дуже
багато випробовувалося психологам і
педагогам та практичними педагогами та
викл удачам та подарункових університетах
fda з мало національної академії
педагогічних наук та рекомендації
професіоналів ахейців був і так ще
бачите в очаковій школі виду then up
making of предмети цілісного та
здоров'я
художня творча фізична культура
там ще практичні психологи здаються
головний щоб дитина розвивала творче
дивно стеба ригла здоров'я і почалася
фізичним з правом вони травмують
сама найменшого школяра ну відра за
виставленням оцінки мацати русі а висимо
валени 9 а.в.
сергейка 6c дуже важливо крем того ми
навіть серйозно поспішав його read та онука
стену стандарті youtube то тисяча
повертається без посередника до річкового
колективної старшої школи всі інші
тренування раніше в ціле спочатку
міністерство сімдесят три сотки на
монтажу ми тепер 40 висимо а лише 52
адже сотки можемо вирішила ти сама
передвічний колик ти вибачиш і коротший у
вас є душ і цекало вчитель біології
то можна взятої профільність і в рамках
багачук програм зарубайте посилання на
вершині біології че української мови
ч святого історії і сідай на дає можна
весь перед їжа профільної школи допомогою
школи повальної будуть і творчі ми і
різьбленим монетним звучанням можна викинути
і навчальний предмети і заміли ти їх там
бальними танцями лдпр школа заклади на
стиміть я кістки своїх чотирьох крачок
може брат і вкрив геометрію фізику в
бік
в біологію і cd лопнеш і позитивні
результати у чому уроки коли
нашими абітурієнтами мій будь не
розкривалася на сонячними за лижного
оцінювання в porsche за всі руки за не
знає які предмет вийшов на друга
місяців якщо українською йому було црб з
коли предмет у париж і я цілую з
гордістю та приємністю you cannot 62
адже сотки zara істру волосся на
тесту ваня помад і матриці тобто
математика вперше за руки обидві знала
історію України і фактично дві-три
таємний дітей так чинно пж і планує
свої жити а пов'язані з обл точними
науками обидва дивись але митрович стандарт
ще до харчування дітей у чортковій школі
у школі залом стандарти вид учню
стандарти творче загроза витковський kit 4
скажіть що німа ставок для кераміки в
куртці в різьбленому вони ти дуже c проблема
лизати і руки астане вають води над що
ми роті в 2012 винайшли новий штат не
розклади для дитини чиїх сотки в перший
коло про білий c3 канал та мінфін сива
можна видати а чого йому садочку на
кожні чотири групи мати художника
обаму звучно ваке ревнива новий штат
розклади для шкіл топ турне
рекомендовані позначає школи
фінансують місцями бюджети і тому я
думаю ще надходив вас доступно уроку ми
будемо про орбіти і про гравців вчить ще
президента волосся ерік уроком дитя че і
творчості нас якраз у рузі рубці
проект закону
екіпажу шкіль не вуста нові в руки та
палати школі риф станцій юних краї
акцію техніки на бачити
ботанічні сади два такі не в криму і
за парижі ми про за наймом переніс ти до
прешова котів а то хто срубає обличчя
захищеними статтями столітті фінансуються
так само перше чехова як заробітна
плата в 4 та цінність могли вести c-dur
вчення президента
вийти в ставків 2 роки за сорок
сотки оха планета за шкільну творчість
на 80 moi je сотки
всіх школі риф ac4 знаєш не мільйони
нарисах багато людей коштувати
дощ та їх психологи у дочку з на школу
здається по дні
залиште мужик і вставляйте все волосся
чітка робота над рівнем
повноцінні психологічні служби
середня сувій безмовного і ces пильний
проектах логічно служба 5 порядкові
типи каятися національну академію
первинних наук і думаючих і при створі
не нових штатних розкладі microsd і підлоги
для середньої школи будемо взуття з кого я
великих місцях ставите харчування ще була
ставка психолог рим того чиї мало видно
війну штатному розкладі ictv можуть години
штатних позицій нам і особистих систер ще
хотів би сказати і це дуже 53 миють
батьки
ми провели експеримент повністю в
харківській та харківській області
і всі ці місяці буквально ось щодо
давно кабінет міністрів на пропозицію
міністерства світлі прийнявши рішення ще ми
поголеною йому до школи abayas кови
medicine а зміг обряди всі 7
ми особистими спеціалістами за пошукову
кардіограму стоматологом
таких цін ну я києва спочатку
ендокринол, а хтось може відмовити столітті
зведену розвідку було у гострій дискусії
3 год розгадав кабінет міністрів алея на
frequency переріз з рішення у хвали а також
пачино я числового початкову руку взуття
з кави профілактичні medicine погляди
будуть повернути і гуси середньої школи
ще держава ясна 2 я про престижність
професії вчителя скільки нуця 1 знай по
найважливіших професій у залі у свиті шимун
і дати в 4-му викладу статусу
державного службу вівці ціну і я думаю
що буду великим стимулом для .
відсотків такими човна година як усі
кажуть і виду цей статус вчителя травня
багата на пориви і свободи в поведінці
застосовано статусом державної служби
єдине харчування і кидіс на потребу я в
регулювання одягаюся і відразу витком
економіки з створення розміру пенсії для
в 4 і викладок і ось вид по видні до
пенсії державна служба вівці ми кілька
разил подавав і так і пропозиції сп
одягаючий і що
крихти дозволити заростання економіки
то ланцюг це не буду ви і вирішено еньші
харчування там ну скажемо у вчителя більше
адже порожній до
більше ща я розповім можна владі себе
реалізувати і єдиної плутанини з більш
не пенсії не хотів би першин близько 100
приймальну скроню з вами так би можете
поділіться а сьогодні буквально кілька
годин тому
кабінет міністрів затвердів пе-2 ще не
по садових оплати всіх противників
бюджетної сфери закриватися в 4
Лікарі числа він і буде
відривати
ще зарплату воно буде спершу перетину і
потім три місяці буде перекований йому
скажімо вчитель вищої категорії з пивним
10 руки любить shape двійковим стажем
такі травня класно керрі замість здобути
підр ще не заробітної плати дупи
говорив розробки прем'єр-міністр
україни Микола азарів dice приблизно
136 145
ревінь і важливо його сказати ще рішення
пропити ви ще не по садових розмірів
садових окладі також разом попит пилками
з великими ведмедика садових розриві
ну то-то не дарма послухали квітка стирчить
великого 15 руки
трудового стажу утримуватиму і b
більше над балку та зрощення абу-дабі
лише пам'ятної не скажемо про кого
10 rockin' кольору шкіри увійшла його ну і
адже видно і категорії там вищої
категорії першин категорії та за всі 3
місяці засічений за люті забери за щось
оперована зарубіжна на плато і виплачена
у відповідь не місяців усім педагоги околиці
димітрович від душі коротко
закупили підручнику ось юмено інформації
іспанському знову перемикання 360
сіл за екземпляри букву р
українською про візуальне світло
початкових зла ковалів значенням польська
нову
троє клас 500 висимо гривень за екземпляр
та чому такі дороги підручником у
секретаря бентеж тиражі 150
двісті-триста приблизно кеніг що взятий
підручнику psyche самі для національних
меншин
дев'ятому ротик вул та popper bool2 чади
ішов зарубати на плато поліграфісти
масив три рази з зросту та картон за 1
t2 диво гаю та підручнику 2009 року 850
сумувати нас перевірялася у приводі
прокуратура
підручних травня редакції не витрачено top
to win приховати авторський гонорар рикша
авторський гонорар
winston вогненний , 30000
бенкет h150 приблизно кінсей забарвлення буквар
для викладання в школах словацьку
румунську можуть вже молитви рей форматі
скільки до що це dies irae не та
петрушки укладаючи школі 16 гривень 70
копійок
відправляю будько вас батьки в ланцюги
дрочені до 5 класу вид 320 до 300 50
100 rynok тварей полі турції хто зможе
купіть книжку 350 стор ніг за 16
дерево не будь ласка хай принеси я буду
дуже вдячний облажується вступ на
компанія лічильник ось абітурієнту 2013
року річки зрад і будуть сонячному
закладено каламуті його не так чому
говорить ще дуже багато дітей zara істру
волосся називатися пузатим 322 с
половиною тисяч ще вижив та його доброго
вільно прийшло за їх 22 сотки в c
випускники по передніх руки мікі просто
хоче пофарбувати і результати там ще
сертифікати син його дія за всі руки
починаючи з 2008
топ такі у вас результат краще то й
подавайте
місяці ступні компанії хотів би сказати і
бочкам та абітурієнтам зі стабільністю
хто не яскравих різних змін не буду
документи приймають Всевишній навчальний
заклад та 31 день поспішав липня до кінця
дня 31 і потім йдуть за конкурсом 3-х або
zara hugo незалежності відра та кен
виїбали всі абсолютно за клади можна
подавати документи за допомогу
електронні системного свято та побічні
с і б ви чай на буду я каміну ламу роті
скажуть чого треба поспішати не повели але
проти
але це просто пов'язана з глибоким
монтажі ним ну і хотів би ще сказати
рахунок правило всім же а прилюдний не
завищується можна і весь кожного
абітурієнта в ступ відійду п'є і я
кивнула я до поз і нову руку до 5
університетів та у кожному університеті
проходить і конкурс за трюми безпосередньо
підготовки пробачиш і коротше за трюми
спеціальностями
вікторію ж просив і обмаже ще plashed
і роботу прямих комісій ми не
погодилася
і я думаю ще змін яких з великих не
буду ну і хотів би сказати ще до дався
ще один конкурсний предмет святого
література
c для тих хто хоче вступати і на
спеціальності культура мистецтва
гуманітарні науки топ можна обирати
Рейчел рахова там у тебе ще й година
ступнів компанії приділіть результати за
ніч та план вулиця за пробувати животи
випробуваному ось це самі минуло уроку 3
результати та син його теоретично можна на
шлюб і до 600 болю та результат від і
статтю документу для середнього світу то
хто за голом ліній до конкурсу абсолютно
на зраді увійти
теоретично можна і весь сівбі 700 болю
600d і можна весь на брат та син його і до
200 болю в найкраща ти стад теоретично
можна і знайденою будеш 1
коди на сітці а всі будуть тільки дано
міністр щоб завершити розумова про все
ланки українського свити давай від ще
одна його , навіть коротко про закон
проект рахунок а ви ще свити 3 варіанти
розглянете буде 20 всім а-валюта
владно ще пропонують і законопроектами
скільки його не додати про
самостійності ви ще дозволяє їм
розпоряджатися своїми кошти набору
теракту rira
що нового я хочу сказати 1000 на
сьогоднішній день на жаль шукаємо ніж алла
самостійності дістати ненавидь не всього
малюється в повному апсиді, а ви завели
копита не я хотів би чим ми абсолютно
пішли вид політизації хочу сказати ще в
кожному проекті та пузаті поза мовою один
проект так я багата більше прав
студентському самоврядування практично
всі говорять промисловості самостійної
копіювання кішкам і сара млинцями там у
пропустіть про міністерство на
парламентських слуханнях
з Кірова над комітетом було навіть просто
включіть робочу групу з автором
3 всіх законопроекті випробувають витоки та
але без над мирних емоцій без парі
уваги політичної та надійності
тисячі нижчих автореф з шкірного
законопроекту взятий кращий за мову і піт і
адже дискримінаційних промов ну
наприклад так звані демократичною
законопроект хоча я противний хто ще 1
2 важко вже коротко там, наприклад, пише
ще ректор та проректор
не може брат і участі ось синього не
ременя успішності в акредитації
з оборона на професію c3 баб ребра ти
ще взятий краще топ то взятий краще
мови у всіх трьох законопроектів бою
думаючих села на прямого не на 1
щення кістки в зник і
дякую вам з була програма повним
грудного з міністром усвяти просто на
око на українську свити побачимо остина
всі добрі